So we've been working in this playground method, I called
mine FilterPlayground where weve been creating queries and adding filters so
that we can learn how to build up queries. Now
this method has very hard wide values in it. So for
example City equals Tokyo and in general you want to
have a bit more flexibility. We want to allow users to
specify the property values that they want to search on.
That's okay though because we've only been using this method for
our own purposes for learning. The real method that
gets invoked by the show conferences page is query conferences.
So, we already defined one implementation for query conferences,
it's very simple. All it does is get all the
conferences. So if we go over to the Show
conferences page, we see all of the conferences that have
been created. We could add a filter here in
the page for example, search for city is Chicago. And
then search but actually, our filter's going to be ignored, even though
up here it tells us that it used the filters, because
on the back end it's calling query Conferences. And the implementation
of query Conferences gets all the conferences and doesn't care about
filters. So what you're going to be doing next is updating
query conferences so that it does respond to the filters. So
there's a few things that you're going to need to do.
One is that you need to copy in the conferencequery.java file.
And put it in the form package. And then you're going to need to change
the signature of query conferences, so that
it takes the conference query form. You're also
going to have to import the conference query
form. Then you need to update the implementation
of query conferences to return the result of ConferenceQueryForm.getQuery.
So you return conferenceQueryForm.getQuery.list. This will
actually work. There's actually a fair amount of
code going on behind the scenes in ConferenceQueryForm, but
if you make these changes, your filters will start
to work. But let's take a look at ConferenceQueryForm.getQuery
so you understand what's going on there. After
you copy conferenceQueryform over, you may find you need
to refresh your project before it actually shows up.
Oh there it is. Good. So, conferenceQueryform has already
been implemented in full. You don't need to implement
anything, but I really encourage you to read through
it and understand what it does. It checks for
inequality filters. Make sure that there's only one inequality
filter in it. It also checks if you have
an inequality filter to make sure that the sort
order's in the right order. And add each filter
in turn. Constructs the query and returns the query.
Another thing I want to bring to your attention
is the enum here that defines the operators. You see
EQ is defined to be equal to equals and
we're going to see how that is used in the API's
explorer. So, here we are in the API's explorer.
We'll go to query conferences, now you see we have
the request body where we can add a property and
the property is filters. And then we add a filter,
you keep clicking and adding these things, so
let's add a property filter on field. But
now, we want to filter on city, equals
something. So we need to specify the operator. Remember
the enum listing operators, where eq was set
to equals? And now we add the value that
we want to check against. I will do
London just cause we know I have some conferences
in London. So this is how you specify the
filters here, unless executed and save its going to work. Oops!
City is not right, I think may be its supposed
to be capital C at this point. So this is
to find in the conference query forms taking a
quick look. Actually I should have entered all capitals for
the city so I'll go back and do that again.
City with a capital, the operator defined as EQ and
the value London. This time we find all the conferences
whose city is London. There isn't that much code that
you need to change to get the show conferences page
to respect the filters. But there is actually quite a lot
of code going on in the conference query form class
that it would be good for you to read through
and understand. Now let's take a look at what happens
in the show conferences page after we deploy the app to
app spot. So here I went to the all tab and we see all the conferences.
Now I'm going to add a filter. And I want to filter on max
attendees, greater than 100. Add
another filter, I just want to get the conferences
in February. The search, let me run this query. I failed to get
the conferences. Now if we run the same
query in the API's explorer and it's max [INAUDIBLE]
greater than 100, start month is two. It's cold
and dark in February so want to find a
nice conference to go to. Then we execute.
And again we've got an error. You see again,
it's the back end error. And this is because
we actually don't have a composite index to satisfy
this query. So this is one danger of giving the
users a free hand in adding filters in any way
they want. You need to be really careful to make
sure that all the necessary composite indexes have been created. So
now the query conferences method can handle multiple filters. But
there's still an optimization that you could make to it. See
here that the query results shows the organizer's display name.
Well the display name must be dynamically calculated for each conference.
Because the organizer's display name is not something we
store in the conference, we dynamically calculate it. So
let's look again at the query conferences method. So,
now I've changed it a bit. So that I get
the, a call conference query form dot get query,
which returns me a list of the conferences, and
then what I'm going to do is iterate over reach
of the conferences, figure out the organizer for that conference,
and then I'm going to preload all the
organizers. And this is going to avoid separate
data store gets for each conference. Because for
each conference, we have to get the profile of
the organizer and then get the display name
after the profile. So this is what the
final implementation of queryConferences would look like. And
you can find this in the Lesson Four folder.